les français se poserait à washington
capitale des etats-unis aujourd'hui à
france piché osb new york jusqu'à
l'hôpital pour l'avenir du concorde le
trafic aérien énorme de cette région
l'aéroport choisi qu'elle est dit et si
encombré damion qu'atterrissent et
d'écoles chose avec la piste ni est
assez des formes par le concorde est un
avion d'une technique très avancé
écartez les trains d'atterrissage dans
latéralement long de la nuit
de plus sa structure est très lente
lorsque le concours drôle sur une piste
déformés il entre en vibrations et des
efforts plus élevé que la normale
s'exerce sur lui
les pilotes l'ont déjà constaté
notamment et à athènes du coup l'an de
la plaine me taire de roulement avant le
décollage il est possible que c'est
devenu parfaitement le tableau de bord
est con trat la larme visuels notamment
en cas de panne les américains aient
quelques années ce problème sur le
bombardiers supersoniques b70 relative
et décoller au moins une fois n'est au
fond des filets ni offert des mesures de
vibrations et ajuster notre sage pour
que les fêtes ces vibrations ne soit
plus n'efface nous l'importance de la
décision de l'autorité portuaire de la
ville de new york
car tant que c'est et ce ne sera pas
fait toutes les rumeurs de son american
home française garderont leur pouvoir
pour ralentir la carrière du concorde